[Music]
billy eilish's new song alludes to
johnny depp's defamation lawsuit against
amber hurt
i'm obsessed with the truth while
performing in the uk on tuesday the 20
year old singer debuts her latest track
titled tv
[Music]
[Music]
as she sings on stage alongside brother
phineas billy references johnny and
amber's triumph as well as the massive
reaction on social media
[Music]
[Music]
and the lyric that follows packs an even
bigger punch we'll have to wait until tv
officially drops to hear billy sing it
but the lyric is the internet's gone
wild watching movie stars on trial while
they're overturning roe vs wade that
last part a reference to news that the
supreme court could potentially overturn
the landmark decision which legalized
abortion on a national scale in 1973.
but billy she's no stranger to bringing
timely subjects into her music
[Music]
in your power she cautions people to
avoid taking advantage of others
and let's take another listen to this
part from billy's show
[Music]
those lyrics seemingly hint at billy's
recent breakup with matthew tyler vorse
we're all just doing our thing you know
what i'm saying
the two first sparked dating rumors in
april 2021 and were spotted out together
a number of times but months into their
relationship and cheating rumors swirled
which led matthew to slam reports he was
unfaithful he wrote on his insta story
nobody cheated on anyone relationships
end simple as that creating rumors and
lying on the internet is dangerous
i don't even know
as for billy well she seems focused on
her career along with phineas she's
coming off big wins from award show
season taking home grammy and oscar
trophies for their james bond title song
[Music]
it has been such a big part of our lives
for so long that the fact that we are
involved at all was
unbelievable
and the approach was very
very exhilarating and like peak life and
also scary um and we just had so much
pressure put on ourselves like we put it
on ourselves we just wanted it to be
perfect and represent daniel craig's
last film and all of his films and how
much you know he put into it and
it just was the most amazing experience
ever
[Music]